c'est l'un des fruits préférés des
français et pourtant on ne connaît pas
si bien que ça la pomme et est à
l'honneur aujourd'hui à
neuvy-saint-sépulchre dans l'indre on
connaît quelques variétés vendu en masse
dans les magasins en réalité il en
existe plus de 400 reportage le garrot
carbo kg en m&a il a même dit combien de
variétés de pommes connaissez vous si
vous regardez dans votre supermarché
probablement pas plus de 5
pourtant dans le berry on recense
presque 200 variétés différentes
alors cette année 4000 personnes se sont
pressées ce week end
et attention ici producteur comme
visiteur il s'agit d'un public averti
regardez ce point là et bien si les
connaisseurs qui vont la manger oui
parce qu'au premier abord donne pas
envie ben voila voila il faut savoir ce
qui est dedans et hors ligne d très
jolie attention hein je prie le plus
moche mais ceux qui connaissent rien ils
vont juger uniquement à l'oeil
voilà on reprend d'une belle passe comme
ça peuvent payer ou reinette bon dos ou
encore la belle fille de l'indre
depuis 36 ans et produits du terroir
attire des milliers de visiteurs pour
leur goût pour leur histoire mais pas
seulement celles plus une ambiance c'est
quelque chose d' innommable c'est
quelque chose qui se ressent avec le
coeur pas avec la tête
vu le nombre de variétés disponibles des
coups de coeur il y en a comme pour ce
futur propriétaire de pommiers à la
recherche d'espèces rustique
ça signifie qu'on peut récolter des
fruits sans avoir besoin de faire une
dizaine de traitement comme c'est à peu
près partout dans les daims dans les
productions normal l'authenticité
une authenticité de goût une
authenticité de production c'est-à-dire
qu'on n'ait pas besoin de venir mettre
des produits chimiques pour récolter de
la pomme
durant tout le week end près de cinq
tonnes de pommes ont été pressés traité
est vendue directement au public une
manière de célébrer ce fruit sous tous
ses aspects